now the Prime Minister has been accused
of using tactics from Donald Trump's
playbook by the new mayor of London
writing in the observer city cancers
David Cameron and his opponent Zac
Goldsmith tried to turn different ethnic
and religious communities against each
other during the mayoral campaign and
just heard emily Thorne briefs reaction
to that and join out by the Conservative
MP Nadine Zoe
well you know Emily Thornbury so many
people and not just from the Labour
Party saying this really was below the
belt the way that that campaign was
afford dog-whistle politics well
obviously I disagree with that and I
tell you why I've known Zac for many
years and Zac is a principled candidate
I've known Sadiq since he entered
Wandsworth council it's a big problem as
he'll find when he is now Mayor of
London his people will actually take
note of what he says and he says it's
different things to different audiences
now during the Labour campaign for
leadership Evette Cooper called out
Jeremy Corbyn for the friends he keeps
Hamas and Hizballah
he calls them friends and of course this
Imam who said some really unsavory
things about women being subservient
about gay people having no rights on the
night of the Paris bombing spoke at a
rally where people called for a rally
Muslims to rally for Islamic state he's
spoken at rallies with his whip
DeHerrera which is a proscribed
terrorist group and cages organisation
that sort of is an apologist for - I
think it's wrong that we don't call out
people when for whatever reason and and
Sadiq may say I was a human rights
lawyer you know that's why I shared a
platform but he also when he became a
member of parliament said look moderate
Muslims will be Uncle Tom's now I know
he's apologized for it but I think it's
wrong that we live in a country where
you can't call out people for bad
behavior just because they have to be
Muslim or Sikh how does that now play
into him being married London are you
still saying then that the jury's out
for you you still want to judge him by
the company he keeps not only the
company keeps it's what he also says I
wanted to govern for the whole of London
I think Sadiq is going to have to go a
long way to get to that place because
his observer Colin today already is
vis-à-vis on the one hand well I'll tell
you on the one hand he says you know I
want to bring London's blunders together
and he says conservative behave like
Trump now Trump is it's basically saying
Muslims are banned from the US that is
not what conservatives believe in I
think siddique needs to think twice
before he biggest to pretend like he's
the man is gonna bring London together
and then starts throwing accusations
like that I think that's actually a very
divisive accusation to say that
conservatives are behaving like Trump is
a terrible thing to say Trump was to ban
Muslims so your question sister Sadiq
has to be look one why did you call
moderate Muslims Uncle Tom's why would
you share a platform with someone who
doesn't believe in gay rights doesn't
believe women should be equal actually
stands up for Islamic state - I had a
rallies just just after bombing in Paris
what is that all up so the bottom the
bottom line is is I mean do you feel
that London is is safe or is less safe
in Sadiq Khan stands well I hope he does
a great job and I wish him luck and good
luck to him because he ran a great
campaign it was difficult of a Zac you
know we've had a Conservative government
six years in always difficult local
elections Zac fought a great campaign
for that election to try and now paint
the conservative campaign as if it was
some sort of sort of device campaign
without looking at you know what did he
do with the seam how come to see man was
so familiar with he he did a video
endorsing so he can 2010 for we're still
fighting the election it's over the the
public of London the voters of London
said well we we don't believe that
London will be less safe we don't
believe that London will be divided if
you become its mam they rejected those
arguments well look Sadiq is won fair
and square and good luck to him and I
congratulate him the moment he won but I
also said to him I hope he governs for
the whole of London and sadik's real
weakness is he will say be at whatever
that audience sees greenness if he's a
flip-flopper he flip-flops those knots
often look I'm just saying to you that
Sadiq will say whatever it takes to
whatever audience to try and win votes
that will be found out now that he has
you know the the big job and City Hall
so Sadiq will have to begin
to behave in a much more responsible way
and I think it's a bad start by saying
that conservatives well I mean not from
Trump debates from the faith side of it
you know the service in Southwark
Cathedral yesterday's and beautiful cost
memorial it's a native thing and I've
got nothing in all I'm saying to use
people like Hugh Dermot other
journalists will begin to take note of
what Sadiq says to different audiences
and call him out just like Yvette Cooper
called that Jeremy Corbyn about his
friends in Hamas and his bullet that is
what I'm saying we shouldn't live in a
society where we fear talking about
these things just because of someone's
own religion
whatever your religion is that's a
wonderful lund
London is a melting pot of all the great
religions and none of no religion
whatsoever so it's a good thing but he
needs to behave responsibly all rights
mr. zahary thank you very much indeed my
pleasure